I'll say this, you are not the oldest guest we've had on the podcast. Yeah, you're very sweet. I just turned 50 a few weeks back. Yeah, you're not even in the top two or three. Yes. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 74, recorded on April 14th, 2022. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we interview Patrice Roy about C++ education, cats, and more. You know, it's interesting. I was thinking about this a bit the other day that I was thinking about the nature of programming books that I think, and maybe this is untrue,
这样说吧，你并不是我们播客节目里年纪最大的嘉宾。对，你人真好。我几周前刚满50岁。对，你连前两三名都排不上。没错。欢迎收看第74期ADSP播客节目，录制于2022年4月14日。我是康纳，今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯一起采访帕特里斯·罗伊，聊聊C++教育、猫咪等话题。你知道，这挺有意思的。前几天我稍微思考了一下这个问题，关于编程书的本质，我认为，也许这不是真的，
but I'll put out my theory here, which is I know a lot of people who write programming books. I have a shelf full of books that are written by my friends. But my impression is that most of them are written with the audience of post-education people, people that have graduated from college that are practicing software engineers or programmers and who want to continue learning their skills and that they're not written as textbooks. And I guess my impression is that like in other fields, that tends to be less the case. It tends to be more that books get written as explicitly as textbooks or as course books. Maybe I'm wrong about that. Maybe my perception is off here.
但我在这里提出我的理论，那就是我认识很多写编程书的人。我的书架上摆满了由我的朋友们写的书。但我的印象是，他们大多数人的目标受众都是受过教育的人，也就是大学毕业、正在从事软件工程或编程工作、想要继续提升技能的人，这些书并不是作为教科书来写的。我的印象是，在其他领域，这种情况往往比较少见。通常情况下，书籍更多是明确作为教科书或课程用书来编写的。也许我的看法是错的。也许我的感知在这里有偏差。
I certainly know that some of the C++ books that I'm familiar with are used as course textbooks, maybe not at the introductory level, but at the higher levels. reminds me of another thing, which is when I was a kid, I would go to conferences all the time with my mother because she's a lawyer and lawyers have to do a certain amount of continuing education every year to keep up with their certifications, their bar association memberships in the US. And one of the ways that you can qualify to do that for that continuing education is to go to a conference and attend some classes there, which is a lot more fun than just like taking some training courses. So of course that's what we would do. But there's no real certification or requirement for that in, you know, the programming industry. So it's sort of up to our own, to each of us to feel motivated to continue learning. Yeah. But if you don't, you're going to get stuck way, way back and you're going to stop following what's going on in the world.
我当然知道，我熟悉的一些C++书籍被用作课程教科书，也许不是在入门级别，而是在更高阶的级别。这让我想起了另一件事，那就是当我还是个孩子的时候，我经常跟着母亲去参加各种会议，因为她是一名律师，律师每年必须完成一定数量的持续教育，以保持他们的资格认证，也就是在美国的律师协会会员资格。而获得这种持续教育资格的方法之一就是去参加会议并在那里听一些课，这比仅仅参加一些培训课程要有趣得多。所以我们当然就是这么做的。但在编程行业中，并没有真正对此的认证或要求。所以这在某种程度上取决于我们自己，取决于我们每个人是否有持续学习的动力。是的。但如果你不这样做，你就会远远落后，并且会停止关注世界上正在发生的事情。
And the, I don't use books written. I have probably the same books you have, but I don't use most of them in my classes. I do suggest chapters from time to time to students. I write my own material. If you look for introductory books, there's one from Yarnet that's kind of cool. The one with the birds on it. Yeah, Tour of C++. No, this is cool if you already know how to program.
而且，我不用写好的书。我可能和你拥有相同的书，但在我的课上我大部分都不用。我偶尔会向学生推荐其中的某些章节。我自己写教材。如果你在找入门书籍，有一本贾恩（Bjarne）写的挺酷的。封面上有鸟的那本。对，《C++之旅》。不，如果你已经懂编程，这本书很酷。
But the Programming Principles book with the swans on it, it's written for undergrads, so it's kind of accessible. And what I like about it is that it goes into detail as to why you do that. How you can do things with the language, what the purpose is, there are pictures of people like Stepanov and they're like, these are the artisans, the people that have worked on this. The language lives through them. I think for beginners, it's an interesting book. It's a bit big maybe for a class, but I don't use it.
但那本封面上有天鹅的《C++程序设计原理与实践》是为本科生写的，所以挺容易读懂的。我喜欢它的一点是，它深入探讨了你为什么要这么做。你如何用这门语言做事，它的目的是什么，里面有像斯特凡诺夫（Stepanov）这样的人的照片，他们就像是工匠，是致力于此的人。这门语言通过他们而延续。我认为对于初学者来说，这是一本有趣的书。作为一门课程来说可能有点大，但我不用它。
So the one that portrayed, there's a few different books by bjarne um uh two of the more mainstream popular ones are uh the swan book one which is uh programming principles and practices using c++ by bjarne the other one which um is one that i is perhaps the most frequently cited introductory C++ book that I know of is the C++ Programming Language book, which has a similar cover in that both covers are blue, but the C++ Programming Language book has mountains on it.
那么帕特里斯提到的那本，贾恩（Bjarne）有几本不同的书，嗯，其中两本比较主流和受欢迎的，一本是“天鹅书”，也就是贾恩写的《C++程序设计原理与实践》；另一本呢，可能是我所知道的被引用最频繁的C++入门书，就是《C++程序设计语言》，它的封面与之类似，两本的封面都是蓝色的，但《C++程序设计语言》的封面上有山。
I don't know if there's a fifth edition of it now. The fourth edition was, I think, the C++11. No, he doesn't want to write one because the language has changed too much. I don't think it's a good introductory book if you've never programmed before. It's a good book to get C++ if you learned something else in the past. Interesting. I know some professors that have used it for an intro programming course that was taught in C++. There's some other books that Bjarne has written, like The Design and Evolution of C++.
我不知道现在有没有第五版。第四版，我想是针对C++11的。不，他不想再写一本了，因为这门语言变化太大了。如果你以前从未学过编程，我认为这不是一本好的入门书。如果你过去学过其他语言，这是一本了解C++的好书。有趣的是，我认识一些教授曾用它来教用C++授课的入门编程课。贾恩还写过其他一些书，比如《C++的演化与设计》。
That's an awesome book. That's really, really, really good. Yeah. I recently was diving in it to find quotes for something. It is a pretty solid book. It gives you perspective as to why things are the way they are, why the model is what it is, and how it differs from other languages. So even if you don't like C++, you should read that book to at least get why the language is what it is. There's purpose to that.
那是一本极其棒的书。真的非常非常棒。是的。我最近深入研究它是为了找一些引言。这真是一本扎实的好书。它能让你明白为什么事物会是现在这个样子，为什么模型是这样的，以及它与其他语言有何不同。所以，即使你不喜欢C++，你也应该读读那本书，至少去理解为什么这门语言会是现在的样子。这是有其目的的。
There's meaning to that. I passed it along to my colleagues and everybody loved it. Even those who don't do C++, they love the book. So you said you develop your own course material. Is that pretty common in the CS world?
这是有意义的。我把它推荐给了我的同事，每个人都很喜欢。即使是不写C++的人，也非常喜欢这本书。所以你说你开发自己的课程材料？这在计算机科学界很常见吗？
Well, I don't know about the CS world entirely. Where I work, many of us do that. Yeah, I'm a bit of a maniac for that, so I write stuff all the time. Now, of course, I'm going to put you on the spot.
嗯，我不太清楚整个计算机科学界的情况。在我工作的地方，我们很多人都这样做。是的，我对这个有点狂热，所以我一直在写东西。现在，当然，我要把你架在火上烤了。
Is it open source? Well, if you can read French, a lot of it is on my website. I have a very big website with awful colors, I know, but that's on purpose. It's an ugly-looking site with lots of contents that people who speak French look at quite a bit. I used to have a password on the site, an ugly looking site with lots of contents that people who speak French look at quite a bit. I used to have a password on the site, but it was a hassle because people couldn't reach it through Google. So I removed that. The course material that's in book format is accessible,
它是开源的吗？嗯，如果你懂法语，很多都在我的网站上。我有一个很大的网站，颜色很糟糕，我知道，但那是故意的。这是一个外观难看但内容丰富的网站，说法语的人经常访问它。我过去在网站上设过密码，这是一个外观丑陋但内容丰富的网站，说法语的人经常访问它。我过去在网站上设过密码，但这很麻烦，因为人们无法通过谷歌访问它。所以我把它取消了。书本格式的课程材料是可以访问的，
but universities, they want to control access a bit. so they're on mobile sites, so it's not as open source as it could be. If I do a big update of everything at some point, now I don't have the time these days, I might just publish the stuff in article form on my site to make it available to more people. So right now, there's an overlap between the book stuff that I write that's for the students and the article stuff that I write that's on my site. In some cases, the site is more up to date. In some cases, the books are more up to date. But the overall stuff is pretty good, I think. It seems to me like we in the soft world world,
但大学方面，他们希望对访问权限进行一些控制。所以它们是在移动端网站上，并没有达到尽可能开源的程度。如果我在某个时候对所有内容进行大更新——现在我这些天没时间——我可能会直接把这些东西以文章形式发布到我的网站上，以便让更多人看到。所以现在，我写的面向学生的书本内容和我写在网站上的文章内容之间存在重叠。在某些情况下，网站上的内容更新。在某些情况下，书里的内容更新。但总体来说，我认为内容还是相当不错的。在我看来，我们软件世界里，
we know how to do open collaboration between different spanning organizations and national boundaries and everything, it seems like, why doesn't every programming language or every field in CS have some open source collaborative effort to, educational material for the university level? That's a very good question. I don't know. There are open classes. Maybe it's just because schools make money out of that. I don't know. It can be that simple. No, why do we sell the standard on ISOs because there's some slight amount of money to be made out of it, I guess. I want people in my classrooms.
我们知道如何在跨越不同组织和国界以及各种边界的各方之间进行开放式协作，这就让人不禁要问，为什么不是每个编程语言或计算机科学中的每个领域都有某种开源协作努力，来为大学水平提供教育材料呢？这是一个很好的问题。我不知道。有公开课程。也许这只是因为学校能从中赚钱。我不知道。事情可能就这么简单。不，我们为什么要在ISO上出售标准呢？因为估计能从中赚取一点小钱。我希望我的教室里有学生。
I want to be with people and talk to them. So I don't want to record my classes and let people watch them from home using popcorn and beer. I prefer them to be having popcorn and beer with me or something. So if I publish everything online, I'm going to be alone in the classroom. It's going to be boring. I have that, yeah.
我想和人们在一起并与他们交谈。所以我不想录制我的课程，让人们一边吃着爆米花喝着啤酒一边在家观看。我更希望他们能和我一起吃爆米花喝啤酒什么的。所以如果我把所有东西都发布到网上，我就会独自一人在教室里。那会很无聊。确实如此，是的。
So do you teach all your classes in French? No, no, no, no. The CP North class will be in English, of course. I'm at the university classes. Yeah, yeah. Sometimes I give, when we have students from outside of Canada quite a bit,
所以你所有的课都是用法语教的吗？不，不，不，不。C++ North（北极星）的课程当然是用英语。我在大学里的课是……对，对。有时我会授课，当我们的外国学生——来自加拿大以外的学生——比较多时，
sometimes they do give bits in English. I answer English questions in English to help people along. But people who come to study with our class, in our classroom, they do have to learn French or speak French. There's a video game graduate class that we've been offering for 17 years now.
有时我确实会用英语讲一部分。我会用英语回答英语提问，以帮助大家跟上进度。但是来我们班、在我们教室学习的学生，确实必须学习法语或说法语。我们开设了一个电子游戏研究生课程，已经开设了17年了。
It's a full-time graduate degree for people who want to come in and participate in game development. In this class, there's a lot of French from France students, but there's also Spanish people. There's people from the Eastern, from Eastern Europe, from South America, from the English speaking world too. And, but the classes are in French. So I can't believe them as much as I can when they're stuck, but otherwise, well, they're learning and they're doing well. And, but the classes are in French. So I can't believe them as much as I can when they're stuck, but otherwise, well, they're learning and they're doing well anyway, they want to work in Montreal. So learning French is important.
这是一个全日制的研究生学位，专门为想要加入并参与游戏开发的人设立的。在这个班里，有很多来自法国的法国学生，但也有西班牙人。还有来自东欧、南欧、英语世界的人。但是，课程是用法语进行的。所以我无法像他们没有遇到困难时那样迁就他们，但除此之外，嗯，他们在学习，而且表现不错。而且，课程是用法语进行的。所以我无法像他们没有遇到困难时那样迁就他们，但除此之外，嗯，他们在学习，而且无论如何他们都表现得很好，他们想在蒙特利尔工作。所以学习法语很重要。
So are there any, are there any challenges to teaching something like C++ in French C++, you know, the, the, the language, you know, and the constructs of the language are obviously sort of uh very english centric in nature are there any you know challenges that come out of that you want the funny ones yes definitely so something like length the t and the h they're so hard to write for french-speaking people they keep mixing them up but no way no it's not that difficult. Most people here in Montreal,
那么，用法语教像C++这样地道的语言有什么挑战吗？你知道，这门语言以及它的结构显然在本质上是非常以英语为中心的。有没有什么你觉得由此产生的挑战？你想听搞笑的吗？是的，绝对有。所以像length中的th，对于说法语的人来说太难写了，他们总是把它们混淆。但其实并没有那么困难。蒙特利尔这里的绝大多数人，
they speak both languages. So they kind of have the basics of English at least. Coming from France, those who come from France, they do have some basics in English too, so they kind of get along. If you ask them to write a paper for you, it might be unpleasant to read because the syntax would be all wrong but you know it's not nothing that difficult the most
他们都会说这两种语言。所以他们至少掌握了英语的基础知识。至于从法国来的人，那些从法国来的人也具备一些英语基础，所以他们勉强能应付。如果你让他们为你写一篇论文，读起来可能会不太愉快，因为语法会全错，但你知道，这并不是什么难事。最
difficult thing is getting people to structure their thought and that's regardless of language so writing smaller functions more focused classes stop using pointers all over the place when you don't need them things like that and that has nothing to do with English or French. Interesting. Yeah. You know, it's, it's, it's interesting to think about, you know, people programming in languages other than English, because I'm not really aware of any programming languages where the
困难的事情是让人们组织他们的思维，而这与语言无关——比如编写更小的函数、结构更专注的类、不要在不需要的时候到处使用指针，诸如此类的事情。这跟英语或法语没有任何关系。有趣。是的。你知道，思考人们使用英语以外的语言进行编程是一件很有趣的事情，因为我真的不知道有什么编程语言，其
constructs are not, or the keywords are not sort of very English-centric. There are some. There are some people who make it in French. It's very, very strange when you look at it, though I've seen that. There's APL. It was more math-oriented.
结构或关键字不是非常以英语为中心的。确实有一些。有些人用法语制作。当你看到它时，感觉非常非常奇怪，尽管我见过。有APL。它更偏向数学。
And there's weird things, yeah. There's weird things like white space where everything that you write, that's not a white space in the company. Yeah. But are there any languages where the keywords are not English keywords? As I said, I know when Dev does that. I sometimes have people having internships in places
还有一些奇怪的东西，是的。有一些奇怪的东西，比如空白，你在其中写的任何东西，只要不是公司里的空白。是的。但是有没有什么语言，其关键字不是英文关键字的呢？正如我所说，我知道有些公司会这么做。我有时会遇到实习生去那些地方
where they use that, but it's kind of... It's understandable if you think of it, because you want to reach a wider audience. So if it's C Sharp, the guy who wrote that is Danish, but it's an English language. And B&R is from the Scandinavian countries too, but your audience is English. Yeah. And for a long time in a language like C++, you couldn't have non-ASCII identifiers or even, you know, there were some compilers that would reject comments if they were not ASCII.
使用这种语言实习，但这种感觉有点……如果你仔细想想，这是可以理解的，因为你想接触更广泛的受众。所以如果是C#，写这个的人是丹麦人，但它是一门英语语言。Bjarne也来自斯堪的纳维亚国家，但你的受众是讲英语的。是的。并且在很长一段时间里，在像C++这样的语言中，你不能使用非ASCII标识符，甚至——你知道的，有些编译器如果注释不是ASCII码就会拒绝编译。
And if I may, I have so much respect for the SG16 people who are working on Unicode for C++. My hat tip to them, they are heroes. Yeah, when is C++ going to get Unicode? I need to be able to write my APL compiler in C++. And I tell you, trying to iterate over a string that does not contain UTF-8 or the 256, it is... You should try Zach Lane's text library, which I think is part of Boost now. Okay. I'll look into it. Yeah. So do you know of any languages that have non-English keywords?
如果可以的话，我对致力于C++ Unicode的SG16成员致以崇高的敬意。向他们脱帽致敬，他们是英雄。是的，C++什么时候才能支持Unicode？我需要能够在C++中编写我的APL编译器。我告诉你，试图遍历一个不包含UTF-8或256字符集的字符串，这简直是……你应该试试Zach Lane的文本库，我想它现在已经是Boost的一部分了。好的。我会去了解一下。是的。那么你知道有哪些语言拥有非英语关键字吗？
I think we asked this question earlier on another podcast and we had a response from someone on Twitter that said, oh, there is actually a language and they linked me to it, but I do not have it top of mind. I'll throw a language out there that doesn't have non-English keywords, but it has a very interesting character set and it's called Jelly. I'll just leave that for the listener to go explore. Just Google Jelly programming language. I've had to use tricks in jobs I've done in the past. In the recent past, that brought me to pre C++98. And you know, the toolbox, when you have a full toolbox, it's very, very useful in those moments. Yeah, I can't imagine.
我想我们之前在另一个播客里问过这个问题，我们在推特上得到了一个人的回应，他说，哦，其实真有这样一门语言，他们还给我发了链接，但我记不清了。我在这里抛出一门没有非英语关键字、但拥有非常有趣的字符集的语言，它叫Jelly。我就把这个留给听众去探索吧。直接在谷歌搜索Jelly编程语言。在我过去的工作中，我不得不使用一些技巧。在不久的过去，这把我带回了C++98之前。你知道，工具箱，当你拥有一个完整的工具箱时，在那些时刻它非常非常有用。是的，我无法想象。
I can't imagine, you know, C++11. That's what I started with because I started working in C++, or not in C++. I started working in the year 2014 and we were using C plus plus 11 at that point. I don't even think the full feature, cause we had some visual studio 2000 something that only had like half of the features still,
我无法想象，你知道，C++11。那是我开始接触C++时使用的版本，或者说我并不是从C++开始的。我是在2014年开始工作的，当时我们使用的是C++11。我甚至不认为那是完整的特性集，因为我们有一些Visual Studio 2000几年的版本，它只有大约一半的特性，
they had the auto keyword and lambdas and stuff like that. And yeah, I can't imagine having to go back. And every time you want to call a bull, you have to build a function object in the form of a struct. There's so many things that I took for granted when I started with the language. And you'd hear about people being like,
它们拥有auto关键字和lambda表达式之类的东西。是的，我无法想象如果必须倒退回去会怎样。每一次你想调用一个bool时，你都必须构建一个struct形式的函数对象。当我刚开始接触这门语言时，有太多东西我都认为是理所当然的。你会听到别人说，
oh, you don't know what it was like. And I'd be like, I don't know. It seems like a pretty nice language to me. But then you realize that there were the, I don't want to call them the dark ages, but just like the pre C++11 ages. And so when you mentioned pre C++98, that's, I can't even, yeah, I can't even imagine.
哦，你不知道以前是什么样的。而我会想，我不知道。在我看来这似乎是一门相当不错的语言。但后来你意识到，存在着——我不想称它们为黑暗时代，而只是C++11之前的时代。所以当你提到C++98之前时，我甚至——是的，我甚至无法想象。
It was a lot of fun because it was an alien place where they had to certify the binaries that they were generating. So they had to compile stuff in debug mode to make sure it was the readable binaries. Then they certified them and it cost so much that they didn't want to change the compilers in any way to make sure that the binaries
那真的很有趣，因为那是一个陌生的世界，他们必须对自己生成的二进制文件进行认证。所以他们必须在调试模式下编译代码，以确保它是可读的二进制文件。然后他们对其进行认证，这花费了如此多的巨资，以至于他们绝不想以任何方式更改编译器，只想确保二进制文件
were as stable as they could. So we were using compilers I had not used in my 23 years of teaching, older stuff than that. So I had to really pick in my old toolbox. If you took a problem like doing function composition, f of g of x, and you try to solve the problem with C++ 98, 11, 14, 17, 20, the evolution of the way you solve that problem is amazing. It's gotten so simple and so clean and so efficient. It used to be doable, but in such convoluted ways. There's a number of things we have learned over time and the language is really helping us. So yeah, we're going to solve problems in many different manners in that class. And I think it's going to be awesome. Patrick, you haven't always been a professor,
尽可能稳定。所以我们当时使用的编译器甚至在我23年的教学生涯中都没用过，比那还要老旧。所以我真的必须在我的旧工具箱里精心挑选。如果你拿一个诸如函数组合（比如f(g(x))）的问题，然后你尝试用C++ 98、11、14、17、20去解决它，你解决这个问题的方式的演变是令人惊叹的。它变得如此简单、干净和高效。过去这是做得到的，但方式却非常繁琐。随着时间的推移，我们学到了很多东西，这门语言确实在帮助我们。所以，是的，我们将用许多不同的方式来解决该课程中的问题。而且我认为这会非常棒。帕特里斯，你并非一直都是教授，
right? I thought you worked on some pretty cool stuff for your professor. Didn't you do flight simulators or something? Yeah, I did research for Hydro-Quebec, which is the biggest company in Quebec here. It's a state-owned thing where we produce electricity. And since we have a lot of water in Quebec, well, we have a lot of electricity. And after that, I did a few years of military flight simulator work. Indeed. So what do you want to know?
对吧？我以为你在当教授之前做过一些相当酷的事情。你是不是做过飞行模拟器之类的工作？是的，我为魁北克水电公司做过研究，这是这里魁北克最大的公司。这是一家国有企业，我们生产电力。由于魁北克水资源丰富，嗯，我们的电力也很充足。在那之后，我做了几年军事飞行模拟器的工作。确实如此。所以你想知道什么？
So was that all in C++? Was that in C++ in the early C++ days? Okay, so now you want the stories. When I got there, the reason I got into flight simulators at first was that I had gotten a scholarship for graduate studies. And I had a baby and another baby was coming along that was not expected. And I looked at my scholarship and said, oh, we're going to have a problem. Money is not going to be sufficient. So I applied there because a friend told me, oh, we're looking for people. I went there and they asked me, do you want to do military work? And I said, no, I don't. And they still hired me and
所以那些全都是用C++写的吗？那是在早期C++时代的C++吗？好吧，既然你这么问，那我就讲讲故事吧。我到那里的原因，我最初进入飞行模拟器领域是因为我获得了研究生学习的奖学金。当时我有一个孩子，另一个意料之外的孩子也即将出生。我看了看我的奖学金，心想，哦，我们有麻烦了。钱根本不够花。所以我去那里应聘，因为一个朋友告诉我，哦，他们在招人。我去了那里，他们问我，你想做军事项目吗？我说，不，我不想。结果他们还是雇用了我，
they offered me a job doing military flight simulators. And I thought about saying no. And then I looked at the money and said, well, I have no choice. But I really, really enjoyed it. I learned a lot of stuff. It was very instructive. It was a milestone in my personal development. It was a very good learning experience. Now, when I got there,
并给我提供了一份做军事飞行模拟器的工作。我当时考虑过拒绝。然后我看了看薪水，心想，好吧，我别无选择。但我真的、真的非常喜欢它。我学到了很多东西。这非常具有教育意义。这是我个人发展中的一个里程碑。这是一次非常好的学习经历。现在，当我到那儿的时候，
my boss was a Fortune 77 expert. And he was, you might not be aware of that, but Fortune 77, you don't have local variables. Everything is static. So if you were trying to write recursive functions, you're going to have a lot of pleasure. He was scared of using the stack for functions because there seemed to be, in his mind, a cost to the stack pointer being incremented and incremented in code. So just selling the fact that we had local variables was a fight. So it was a mixed L4477 and size NCC that we had to do.
我的老板是一位Fortran 77专家。而且，你可能不知道这一点，在Fortran 77中，你没有局部变量。所有东西都是静态的。所以如果你试图编写递归函数，你会过得很“愉快”。他害怕在函数中使用栈，因为在他看来，在代码中递增栈指针似乎是有成本的。所以仅仅推销“我们拥有局部变量”这一事实就经历了一场恶战。因此我们不得不将Fortran 77和C混合使用。
Now, I was a C++ aficionado back then already. With the C++ I knew, which was much more limited than what I know today. So I had built a framework of macros to make my C code behave kind of like C++ with initialization and stuff, which generated a lot of code because I tried to be as clean as I could. And I actually saw an error message when I was there that claimed that the function had gotten too big through macros and the compiler refused to optimize it. I'd never seen that before. There are too many lines
当时的我已经是C++的狂热爱好者了。凭着我当时所掌握的、比今天要局限得多的C++知识，我构建了一套宏框架，让我的C代码表现得有点像带有初始化等特性的C++。由于我试图让代码尽可能干净，这生成了大量的代码。事实上，我在那里时看到了一条错误消息，声称该函数通过宏变得太大了，编译器拒绝优化它。我以前从未见过这种事。代码行数太多了，
and I refuse to optimize your code. Go to hell. Kind of sounded like that. So yeah, so I did that. I worked on mostly helicopters that went to R but also did search and rescue. I worked on communication channels and I worked on a system that simulated voice messages within the simulated helicopters.
我拒绝优化你的代码。见鬼去吧。听起来差不多就是这个意思。所以，是的，我就这样做了。我主要从事飞机的研发，这些飞机去过救援现场，但也执行搜救任务。我研究过通信通道，还研究过一个在模拟直升机内部模拟语音消息的系统。
Voice is interesting because it's a real-time system. It's hard real-time. The people in the helicopter, they have to be able to tune into a radio and listen to, believe it or not, the weather. That's very important for them because they don't see what they're doing. They're guided mostly because there's always fog and stuff. They want to go to such and such airport and they want to know what the weather is to actually do their approach properly and don't kill themselves or anything. And the executive system that we had there, so it was a layered thing with, see it as a four-level tree. The topmost part was a critical band where things have to be done at every iteration of the system.
语音很有意思，因为它是一个实时系统。它是硬实时系统。直升机上的人员必须能够调谐到某个无线电频率，并收听——信不信由你——天气预报。这对他们来说非常重要，因为他们看不到自己正在飞行的状况。他们主要依靠引导，因为总是大雾弥漫什么的。他们想要去某个机场，并且需要知道天气情况，以便正确地进行降落进近，而不会把自己给撞死或发生别的意外。我们在那里拥有的执行系统，它是一个分层结构，你可以把它看作一个四层树。最顶层是关键频段，必须在系统的每一个迭代周期中完成各项任务。
And that's life-saving stuff. And as you go along down the tree, things get less and less critical. So they might skip turns from time to time. And I happened with the system to have pieces on each and every level of the system. So I got the whole experience. Yeah. And it was the biggest flight simulator in the world back then. So by far.
这是救命的事情。随着你沿着树向下延伸，事情变得越来越不那么关键。所以它们可能会不时跳过某些周期。而我的系统恰好在系统的每一层都有代码组件。所以我获得了全面的体验。是的。而且那是当时世界上最大的飞行模拟器。远远超过其他。
So it was seen as a research project, but our motto was at CAE, we can. So we said yes to everything, regardless of whether it made sense or not. And I was given 50 hours to take this bit of Fortran code that worked on a single helicopter and make it work on a system of helicopters that behaved as a unit
所以它被视为一个研究项目，但我们在CAE的座右铭是：我们能行（at CAE, we can）。所以我们对所有事情都说“好”，不管它有没有意义。我当时被给了50个小时的时间，去把一段在单架直升机上运行的Fortran代码拿过来，让它在一组通过多台机器共享世界的直升机系统上运行，
when sharing a world through many machines. Pure parallel code. It was concurrency and shared memory and stuff, which of course made no sense. It took three hours to do. So it was three hours, three years, three years to do instead of 50 hours. It was crazy. And if you want the inside story, when I saw this, I said, I'm never going to write that in Fortran 77. Makes no sense to me. It's way too hard. So I asked for budget to rewrite it in C because C++ was out of the question. It was too scary. And they said, no, we don't have the money. So I went on my own at night, then I wrote the whole thing in C on my own time. And I committed it and told nobody for a few weeks.
使其作为一个整体协同工作。纯并行代码。那涉及并发、共享内存之类的东西，这当然毫无道理。这项工作花了整整三个小时才完成。不对，是花了三年，花了三年时间才完成，而不是50个小时。这太疯狂了。如果你想听内幕消息，当我看到这个情况时，我说，我绝不用Fortran 77写这个。这对我来说毫无道理。这太难了。所以我申请了预算，用C语言重写它，因为用C++是想都别想的。那太吓人了。然后他们说，不，我们没有钱。所以我晚上自己一个人干，利用自己的时间用C语言重写了整个东西。我提交了代码，几周内谁也没告诉。
And when everybody saw that it worked, then I told them. And everyone was relieved because nobody wanted to do that in Fortran anyway. But yeah, so that's it. What year was this? When was this? I was there between 1995 and 1998. Wow. Those were really the early days of C++ and you were already using it, already familiar
当每个人都看到它能工作时，我才告诉了他们。每个人都如释重负，因为无论如何也没有人想用Fortran来做这件事。不过，是的，就是这样。这是哪一年？这是什么时候？我是在1995年到1998年之间在那里的。哇哦。那真的是C++的早期时代，你当时就已经在使用它了，而且对它很熟悉
with it. Wow. Yeah. I started using C++ around 1993 or something. I'm old. Sorry. I'll say this. You are not the oldest guest we've had on the podcast.
了。哇。是的。我大约在1993年左右开始使用C++。我很老了。抱歉。这样说吧。你并不是我们播客节目里年纪最大的嘉宾。
You're very sweet. I just turned 50 a few weeks back. Yeah, you're not even in the top two or three. You're very sweet. To be honest, I would have stayed at CE if I had not gotten a teaching opportunity but I wanted to do teaching in the long term and when I got an offer I said well if I don't
你真贴心。我几周前刚满50岁。是的，你甚至排不进前两三名。你人真好。老实说，如果我没有得到教学机会，我本来会留在CAE的，但我长期以来一直想从事教学工作。当我得到一个offer时，我想，如果我现在不
do it right now I might never do it so let's just do the move it cost me a lot of money to do that because I was well paid at CE so how many kids do you have now you mentioned two I can hear some kittens in the background I was really hoping we'd get to see one How many kids do you have now, Patrice? You mentioned two. I can hear some kittens in the background.
去做，我可能永远都不会去做了，所以干脆跳槽吧。这样做花了我很多钱，因为我在CAE薪水很高。那么你现在有几个孩子？你刚才提到两个。我能听到背景里有小猫的叫声。我真的很希望能看到一只。你现在有几个孩子，帕特里斯？你提到了两个。我能听到背景里有小猫的叫声。
I was really hoping we'd get to see one. No, they're sleeping right now. Most of them, I just fed them like 15 minutes ago. Someone had some cats or something that was going meow. And I'll keep that in. I'll keep that in. Everyone's going to get to hear Connor as a cat. I do know you have a lot of pets though, Patrice.
我真的很希望能看到一只。不，它们现在在睡觉。大部分是这样，我大约在15分钟前刚喂过它们。刚才有人养的猫或者别的什么东西在“喵喵”叫。我会把这个保留下来。我会把这个保留下来的。每个人都能听到康纳像猫一样叫。不过我知道你有很多宠物，帕特里斯。
There are seven cats at home. There's one dog, three parrots, a hamster. The number of cats has gone up to as high as 30 from the beginning. But we have a shelter. Okay. I was about to say, like you basically have a farm or a shelter. Yeah. Well, I have a wife who works at the veterinarian's clinic who's an expert in cat and dog nutrition so she works from home mostly and she guides
家里有七只猫。还有一只狗、三只鹦鹉、一只仓鼠。从一开始算起，猫的数量最多曾达到过30只。但我们有一个收容所。好的。我刚想说，你基本上是在经营一个农场或收容所。是的。嗯，我有一个在兽医诊所工作的妻子，她是猫狗营养学专家，所以她主要在家办公，她会指导
people who have problems it's a free service and people just call that in or the the scheduled meeting with her and they have an hour and she listens to what kind of problem they have and she guides them through their nutritionary needs. We have seven cats of our own. They're all kind of weird, like with weird paws or weird defects. One of them is missing a tail, whatever. And we take, in Quebec, most people move around July. There's a tradition where first of July, everyone's moving. And people tend to abandon their cats around that time, which is very sad. When we were leaving, our previous house was about 15 minutes drive from where I live now. And my wife was in the administration. She was managing
那些遇到问题的人。这是一个免费服务，人们只需打电话进来，或者预约和她见面，她们会谈一个小时，她会倾听他们遇到了什么样的问题，并指导他们满足宠物的营养需求。我们自己养了七只猫。它们都有点奇怪，比如长着奇怪的爪子或者有生理缺陷。其中一只没有尾巴，诸如此类。我们收养——在魁北克，大多数人都在7月份搬家。这里有一个传统，即7月1日每个人都在搬家。人们往往会在那个时候抛弃他们的猫，这非常令人难过。当我们搬家时，我们以前的房子离我现在住的地方大约有15分钟的车程。我妻子当时在搞行政管理。她管理着
kind of a shelter organization where they rescued cats, sterilized them, vaccinated them, and let them go. When they got pregnant cats, it was more complicated because you don't want to sterilize them with the babies in. We used to take the cats
某种收容所组织，在那里他们会救助猫咪、为它们做绝育、接种疫苗，然后再放归。当他们遇到怀孕的母猫时，情况就更复杂了，因为你不能带着腹中的幼崽给它们做绝育。我们过去常常把猫
down, let them have the babies, and then sterilize everyone and vaccinate everyone and find homes for them. So we kept on doing that when we moved. So that's why sometimes we have as high as 30 cats because there was one time two years ago, three years ago, when we had four pregnant cat ladies in the span of a month and all of them gave birth to four to six kittens. So they each had their own room such that they didn't fight. And there were seven little boxes in the span of a month, and all of them gave birth to four to six kittens. So they each had their own room, so they didn't fight.
带下来，让它们把小猫生下来，然后给所有人做绝育和接种疫苗，并为它们寻找领养家庭。所以当我们搬家时，我们一直这样做。这就是为什么有时我们的猫多达30只的原因，因为两三年前曾有过这样一段时间，在一个月的时间里，我们迎来了四只怀孕的母猫，它们全都产下了四到六只小猫。所以它们每个人都有自己的房间，这样它们就不会打架。在一个月的时间里，有七个猫砂盆，
And there were seven litter boxes to be twice a day. So if I understand correctly, then it is likely that you will, that right before C++ North, you will have additional cats that will end up in the house because everybody's moving in July. It's absolutely probable. Yeah, that's the kind of thing that happens. It's happened less with COVID because people move less. But yes, we do that. And then why do we do that?
需要一天清理两次。如果我没理解错的话，那么很有可能，就在C++ North大会之前，你们家里又会多出一些最终落脚的猫咪，因为大家都在7月份搬家。这绝对是有可能的。是的，这就是那种经常发生的事。由于疫情的原因这种情况变少了，因为人们搬家变少了。但是的，我们确实这么做。然后，我们为什么要这么做？
Because we can. I mean, my wife is good at this. We can, when they need special medication or treatment, we can actually do that. We can prepare milk and feed them when the ladies cannot do that with small, I don't know what the English word for that is, but when you feed babies with bottles, so we can do that with cats.
因为我们能做到。我的妻子很擅长这个。当它们需要特殊的药物或治疗时，我们实际上能够做到。我们可以准备牛奶并在母猫无法喂养时用奶瓶喂它们，我不知道英语里那个词怎么说，但就是用奶瓶喂幼崽，我们可以用猫咪来做到这一点。
They're very tiny bottles. And when the lady cats cannot do it, because already they kind of lick the babies to make them pee and stuff. Well, you need to do it yourself. You need to put the baby cats on top of the sink or the toilet. You need to message them properly such as the pee and stuff. And then you wash your hands, of course. So I do that quite a lot. How do you put pictures of these cats in your, in your talks?
那是非常小的奶瓶。当猫妈妈无法做到这一点时——因为通常它们会舔小猫来刺激它们排尿什么的。嗯，你得自己动手。你得把小猫放在水槽或马桶上方。你得正确地给它们按摩，这样它们才能排尿什么的。当然，之后你要洗手。所以我经常做这个。你是如何在你的演讲中放这些猫咪的照片的？
You have to start if you don't. I've done that once or twice with a few cats. My wife has a Facebook account. She's more of a picture person than I am. But I haven't done that. I'm not a big picture person, but I have done talks with pictures of cats. But I feel it feels weird to me to advertise that during my talks. But I do talk about them.
如果你还没开始的话，你得开始了。我用几只猫做过一两次。我妻子有一个Facebook账号。相比我，她更喜欢发照片。但我没怎么做过。我不是一个特别喜欢放照片的人，但我确实做过带有猫咪照片的演讲。不过我觉得在演讲中宣传这些感觉有点怪。但我确实会谈论它们。
And you talked about the kids. I have five. There are only two left at home because theirs are all gone. One of them is going to be a kind of lawyer soon. One of them is a dance instructor. One of them is a literature major. And I have a teenager and a young kid who's still in elementary school. And you teach it to different schools. And I have a PhD, which I did along the way. And I used to be a union worker too, because I used to be part of the teacher's union. Well, one of the executive members. And I do the work, you know.
你谈到了孩子们。我有五个。家里只剩下两个了，因为其他的都搬出去了。其中一个很快就要成为某种律师了；其中一个是舞蹈教练；其中一个是文学专业；我还有一个十几岁的青少年和一个还在上小学的幼子。你在不同的学校教书。我还有一个博士学位，这是我在兼顾的过程中完成的。我过去还是个工会成员，因为我曾经是教师工会的一部分。嗯，是执行委员之一。而且我一直在干活，你知道的。
What's the secret, Patrice? Ask Bryce, he never sleeps. I mean, I do sleep from time to time. Bryce doesn't sleep, so. No, I had to take that out of my profile signature because now I sleep. My email signature for many years said sleep is for the weak, but now that I'm an old man,
秘诀是什么，帕特里斯？问布莱斯吧，他从不睡觉。我的意思是，我偶尔还是会睡觉的。布莱斯不睡觉，所以……不，我不得不从我的个人签名里把那句话删掉了，因为我现在睡觉了。我的电子邮箱签名很多年都写着“觉是留给弱者的”，但现在我老了，
I go to sleep. When I feel tired, I go to sleep. I can tell you that. Since I've seen Michael Wong's resume, I don't feel like I work a lot anymore because Michael is ridiculously busy. It makes no sense. I don't know why he does it. But yeah, I get up early, I go to bed late, and I try to do a proper job. So that's what I do.
我开始睡觉了。当我感到疲倦时，我就去睡觉。我可以告诉你的是，自从我看到迈克尔·王（Michael Wong）的简历后，我觉得自己再也不算努力工作了，因为迈克尔忙得荒唐。这简直没道理。我不知道他为什么要这么做。不过，是的，我起得早，睡得晚，并且努力把工作做好。这就是我所做的。
You know what's the most difficult these days? There's been a lowering in literacy skills. So people learning to make meaning out of the text that they read. So in university, in college these days, what I noticed for less than two or three years, you have to repeat more what you say because people, they can read out loud the words, but the phrases don't make the same sense to them as it used to. So the thing I say the most these days is please reread the directives to make sure you've got them right. Please mark down what you've done because you probably didn't get it properly.
你知道现在最困难的是什么吗？读写能力出现了下降。也就是人们理解他们所阅读的文字含义的能力在下降。所以在如今的大学和学院里，我注意到在不到两三年的时间里，你必须更多地重复你所说的话，因为人们虽然能够大声朗读出这些字词，但这些句子对他们而言已经不像过去那样有意义了。所以我这些天说得最多的一句话是：请重新阅读指令，确保你完全理解了。请记下你所做过的事情，因为你可能没有弄对。
And sometimes they give me homework back and I have to give back saying, that's not why I asked, please do it again. And when at some point I sat down with them and I've done that many times in the last few weeks, I read out loud with them the words and said, I never saw that paragraph. It's the first one in the actual text. But it just came over. You don't see it. So my fight these days is make sure you read,
有时他们把作业交回来，我不得不退回去说：“这不是我要求的，请重新做。”有时在某些时候，我和他们坐下来——在过去的几周里我这样做过很多次——我和他们一起大声朗读那些词句，然后说：“我从来没见过那个段落。”“这是正文里的第一段啊。”但它就是被忽略了。你根本看不见它。所以我现在的斗争是确保你们去阅读，
because there's been a lowering during COVID times of reading skills. Yeah, I was just about to ask. You said the last one to two years. Do you think that that's related to the move to online? Yeah. Yeah, I'm pretty sure there's an impact because it didn't used to be there's always problem with people having problems with their reading skills but to generalize like that inside i saw almost half of the students these days
因为在疫情期间，阅读能力出现了下降。是的，我正想问。你刚才说过去一到两年。你认为这与转向线上教学有关吗？是的。是的，我确信这产生了影响，因为以前并非如此——人们总是会遇到阅读能力方面的问题，但像现在这样普遍存在，我看到差不多有一半的学生都是这样。
interesting i used to have to uh at the top of my exams i would write rtq which stood for read the question and this is not necessarily because I have a low proficiency in reading. Like I read quite a bit, but especially with math exams, I get very, very excited because I know I like, I see the structure of the problem in a few numbers and I just assume, Oh, I know, I know what to do here. And then I'll end up, you know, there's times where I failed tests because I didn't actually read what it was asking me to do. And I just sort of very quickly got excited, went ahead and answered. And then I got back and it would say, you know, 40 percent. And I'd be like, what? What happened?
有趣的是，我以前不得不在考试的最上方写上“RTQ”，意思是“阅读题目”（Read The Question）。这不一定是因为我的阅读能力低。比如我读的书相当多，但特别是在数学考试时，我会变得非常非常兴奋，因为我知道我喜欢它，我在几个数字中就能看到问题的结构，然后我就会想，“哦，我知道了，我知道这里该怎么做了。”最后，你知道的，有时我考试不及格，是因为我根本没有仔细阅读它要求我做什么。我只是非常快地兴奋起来，直接开始答题。等我拿回试卷，上面会写着，你知道的，40分。然后我会想，“什么？发生了什么？”
I like I nailed that. And then I would go back and the commentary from the prof or the teacher would be like, this is not what was requested. You know, please read more carefully. And yeah, that's, that's sometimes there's this interesting phenomenon that sometimes people that have a high reading proficiency and who can read very quickly will have trouble like recognizing an error in a text because they read through it so quickly that they like, you know, they, they, they just complete their mind, their head just like corrects whatever the error was in the sentence. And yeah. If you allow me, we used to, me and one of my close colleagues,
我觉得我明明考得极好。然后我翻回试卷，教授或老师的评语会是：“这不是所要求的。”“请更仔细地阅读。”是的，有时候会存在这样一个有趣的现象：有时阅读能力很高、能读得非常快的人，在识别文本中的错误时反而会有困难，因为他们读得太快了，以至于像——你知道的，他们的大脑会自动脑补并纠正句子中的任何错误。是的。如果你允许的话，我和我的一位密友过去常常
we used to have this exam. We passed to first year students like midway through the semester where there were objective questions. So you have a choice of answers. And in one of them, the answer was pseudocode. But we put pseudopod, P-O-D, instead of code, which is a tentacle as first answer. And pseudocode was the fourth one. And the only ones that missed it were the good students because they read too quickly.
有这样一份考试。我们在学期中途发给大一学生，里面包含客观题。所以你有一组答案可供选择。其中一个题目的答案本来应该是伪代码（pseudocode）。但我们把第一个答案写成了伪足（pseudopod，P-O-D，而不是code，意思是触手）。而真正的“伪代码”是第四个选项。结果只有好学生答错了，因为他们读得太快了。
So they saw the first word and I used to give them, I used to draw small squids and hand them over in the class, the public saying, you got a prize today because you read too quickly. So yeah, you only hit the bad ones, the good students with that. It's funny, my dad would always joke to me like when I was in high school and if I did poorly on something,
所以他们看到了第一个词。我过去常常画一些小乌龟，然后在课堂上当众发给他们，说：“你今天得了个奖，因为你读得太快了。”所以，是的，这个陷阱只坑害了那些好学生。有趣的是，我爸爸在我上高中时总是跟我开玩笑，如果我某门课考砸了，
he'd ask me and I'd say, ah, I didn't do that good. But I mean, that's just because I didn't read the question correctly or whatever. And, you know, so I knew what I was doing.
他会问我，而我会说：“啊，我考得不太好。但那只是因为我没有正确阅读题目之类的。”所以其实我是懂的。
I just didn't. And it went on into university. And like, whenever I would talk to him on the phone, he would just like, he just sort of chuckle. Cause like, it's his joke is like,
我只是没有……这种情况一直持续到了大学。而且——每当我给他打电话时，他就会咯咯笑。因为——他的笑话就像是……
oh, you didn't read the question. Oh, surprise, surprise. You know, that you did the only his joke is like, oh, you didn't read the question. Oh, surprise, surprise. You know, that you did, the only reason you did poorly is not because you didn't prepare. It's because you don't have time to like do the most important thing, which is to figure out what the test or the class is asking from you. At the level where we are, it's reading your messages.
哦，你没有读题目。哦，真是意料之中。你知道的，他唯一的笑话就是，哦，你没读题目。哦，真是意料之中。你知道的，你之所以表现不好，不是因为你没有准备，而是因为你没有时间去做最重要的事情，也就是弄清楚测试或课程到底在要求你什么。在我们这个水平，其实就是阅读你的错误信息。
Professionals, they don't read messages well enough. But they're often quite talkative. So when you read them properly, you kind of grasp the gist of what's missing and work your way through.
专业人士，他们对错误信息的阅读还不够仔细。但他们通常挺健谈的。所以当你仔细阅读时，你就能大致抓住缺少了什么，然后顺藤摸瓜解决问题。
So making them learn to read their messages is a fight because after two years in school, they still don't do it. What's super, super interesting
所以教他们学会阅读错误信息是一场硬仗，因为在学校待了两年后，他们依然不会这么做。超级、超级有趣的是
about that is a lot of the times in a production code base, you'll get some crazy template metaprogramming, 100 lines, everyone's seen it. And my gut reaction is like, I don't know what this is doing. And then I'll go to Godbolt. I'll get some minimal reproducing version of it. And it'll be the same sort of error.
关于这一点，很多时候在生产代码库中，你会遇到一些疯狂的模板元编程，有一百行之长，所有人都见过。我的直觉反应通常是：我不知道这在搞什么鬼。然后我会去 Godbolt，获取一个最简复现版本。结果发现其实是同一种错误。
But now because it's a minimal, you know, reproduce and like, I know exactly what's happening. I'll just read it. And it'll actually tell me like in the midst of all the garbage, like the exact problem, which the previous error actually also said, I just, I just like, I saw it and my eyes glazed over and I was like, oh, I'll go fix this and God bolt. But like, it's like you said, a lot of the times the error messages, like in the midst of all the angle brackets,
但现在因为它是最小化的，你知道的，能够复现，而且我知道到底发生了什么，我就会去读它。它其实会在各种垃圾信息中直接告诉我确切的问题，而之前的错误其实也说过了，只是我当时看了一眼就大脑一片空白，心想：‘哦，我去 Godbolt 里修一下。’但就像你说的，很多时候错误信息，在无数尖括号的包围中，
there is actually very specifically what your issue is. If you had just taken the time to read it, which I rarely do, I just go to Godbolt. So there's something there that we always complain about how awful they are, but a lot of the times in the midst of that awfulness is actually the key to the problem. We just don't. You're making a point for writing smaller functions and smaller meta functions.
其实非常明确地指出了你的问题所在。只要你肯花时间去读一下——虽然我很少这么做，我总是直接去 Godbolt。所以这里有个现象，我们总是抱怨它们有多糟糕，但很多时候，在那片混乱之中其实正藏着问题的关键。我们只是不去看。你这也是在强调编写更小的函数和更小的元函数。
If you write small things, it's so much easier to find your way around. You almost don't debug if you don't do that. Yeah, that's true. One thing that I, I've run into that
如果你写的东西很小，找起路来就会容易得多。如果不这样做，你几乎没法调试。是的，确实如此。我遇到过的一件事是
a lot too, Connor, and I do the same thing where if it's, if it looks like it's going to be hard, I'll just go to Godbolt to try to reproduce it there. Especially a lot of the bugs,
也有很多次，康纳，我也做同样的事情，如果看起来很难，我就会直接去 Godbolt 尝试复现。尤其是很多漏洞，
because I mostly work in compilers these days, a lot of the problems that I run into are bugs that are actually in the compiler. And so if it's a compiler, if I think it's a compiler bug, my first reaction is to reduce it down to, you know, the form that a compiler writer wants it in, which is, you know, pure, like ideally pre-processed source code that's like minim, that has no includes or anything so that it's an easy test input to reproduce. But one thing that I've often done with more complex template errors is I'll dump the error
因为我最近主要从事编译器工作，我遇到的很多问题其实都是编译器本身的漏洞。所以如果是编译器问题，如果我认为是编译器漏洞，我的第一反应就是把它精简到编译器开发者希望看到的形式，也就是纯粹的、理想情况下经过预处理的源代码，要足够精简，没有包含任何头文件之类的内容，这样它就是一个容易复现的简单测试输入。但我处理更复杂的模板错误时经常做的一件事是，把错误信息
message to a text file, and then that lets me go and do some reformatting of it. If it's an error message where it's complaining about the second argument, the template argument in a template that has four or five arguments and maybe one of them is just a string of nonsense, the default way that most compilers format that is just to give it to you all as one long line. And so oftentimes, if I take it into a text editor, and if I just start manipulating it, put each argument on one line, then it becomes a lot easier for me to figure out, oh, this is actually what the problem was. You're making a point for indentation of code, too, is the same thing.
导出到一个文本文件中，然后我对它进行一些重新格式化。如果某个错误信息在抱怨某个模板中的第二个参数——这个模板有四五个参数，其中可能有一个只是一串毫无意义的字符串——大多数编译器默认的格式化方式就是把它全写在长长的一行里。所以很多时候，如果我把它放进文本编辑器中，开始对它进行排版，把每个参数放到单独的一行上，那么弄清楚‘哦，这其实才是问题所在’就会变得容易得多。你这也是在强调代码缩进的重要性，道理是一样的。
Yeah, yeah, exactly. On the other hand, some of the other compilers I work with, they try to do that sort of formatting for you in their error messages. And it's hard to identify what the optimal formatting of an error message is going to be in the generic case. And so I think oftentimes it's good for us as programmers to take the error diagnostic and, see if we can sort it into something that's a little bit more manageable ourselves. I think there's a, there's a tool that Vittorio Romeo has written, but I do not recall the name of,
对，对，确实如此。另一方面，我合作过的一些其他编译器，它们会在错误信息中尝试为你做这种格式化。但在一般情况下，很难确定错误信息的最佳格式化方式应该是什么样的。所以我认为，作为程序员，我们自己拿到错误诊断信息，然后看看能不能把它整理得更容易处理一点，往往是一件好事。我认为 Vittorio Romeo 写过这样一个工具，但我记不起名字了，
but it actually is like you pipe your compilation into this. And then you can set the level of like nesting of the brackets that it shows. So by default, it it collapses all of it. And then you get a much more succinct. And the idea is you can keep running it and increasing the level until the message or the info that you need is there, which is kind of a neat idea. One interesting problem that we have in the C++ space is the question of when you dump
但它的功能是这样的：你可以把编译输出通过管道传给它。然后你可以设置它显示的括号嵌套层级。所以默认情况下，它会折叠所有的括号，你会得到一个简明得多的版本。这个想法是你可以不断运行并增加层级，直到你需要的消息或信息出现为止，这真是一个绝妙的主意。我们在 C++ 领域遇到的一个有趣问题是，当你想输出
out an error that's got some sort of stack to it, like template instantiation stack, which direction do you output? Most compilers output from the original source of the error all the way down to where it was triggered from. And I think that's actually not very helpful because like you, you see it then when you get this long error dump, the last thing is going to be the first thing that you see. The last part of the error must be the first thing you see. And if you see instantiated from here within main, you know,
带有某种堆栈信息的错误时，比如模板实例化堆栈，你应该按哪个方向输出？大多数编译器都是从错误的最初源头一直输出到触发它的地方。我认为这其实并没有什么帮助，因为像你一样，当你看到这一大串冗长的错误输出时，你看到的第一件事其实是最后发生的事。错误的最后一部分必须是你看到的第一部分。如果你看到的是“在 main 中从此处实例化”，你知道的，
the place where it was instantiated from is maybe not the most helpful thing. Oftentimes the most helpful thing is what the, the root of root of that tree of this was the error that happened. I think the only compiler I've seen that does it the inverse direction, if I recall correctly, is I think Circle does it the other way around, which I have found to be quite interesting. I'd love to see that be a switch for which direct, which, which, you know, to reverse the template instantiate the error instantiation, like message order. I'd love to see a switch for that so that I could, I would probably switch it by default. Cause like almost always what I do is I, is I scroll up to the start of the error and I read the error from the start
进行实例化的那个地方可能并不是最有帮助的信息。通常最有帮助的信息是该错误树的根源：这就是发生的错误。我想我见过的唯一一个采用相反方向输出的编译器——如果我没记错的话——应该是 Circle 采用的是相反的方向，我发现这非常有趣。我很希望能有一个开关来控制方向，也就是颠倒模板实例化错误消息的输出顺序。我很希望能有这样一个开关，这样我默认就会把它切过去。因为几乎我每次做的事情都是滚动到错误的起点，然后从起点向下阅读错误
down. Do you need a clang format kind of tool for error messages? Yeah. I was just thinking that I was thinking I want clang format for error messages. Yeah. That would be cool. It would be a nice project to write. Yeah. Somebody, somebody get on that. Yeah. I'm sure there's something out there. If not after this podcast, there will be. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你是不是需要一个像 clang format 那样的工具来处理错误信息？对，我刚才就在想这个，我在想我想要一个用于错误信息的 clang format。对，那太酷了。写这样一个项目会挺不错的。对，谁来搞定这个吧。对，我相信外面肯定已经有这样的工具了。如果没有的话，在这个播客之后就会有了。感谢收听，希望你们喜欢，祝大家有美好的一天。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。